curieuse et se vautre alors vous êtes
académicien français oui alors
évidemment je vous faire une interview
proust express c'est ce que tout le
monde croit que c'est une interview de
bernard pivot mais en fait c'est le
questionnaire de proust
simplement je vais vous demander c'est
très important de répondre en faisant
des fautes de français comme vous et
académicien des fautes de français au
bois sans rien n'est plus facile sera
par exemple si je vous dis vous fait
couper les cheveux tous les combien vous
me répondez je vais au coiffeur une fois
par mois d'accord d'accord j'ai toujours
quoi faire
une fois le mois on ne bouge pas pendant
le génial dans le cauchemar dans le
qinghai
bien vous êtes prêts toujours près bien
alors quel est pour vous le comble de
rente bien flux quel est pour vous le
comble de la misère le compte de la mise
à oui alors c'est les fautes et les
fautes pour lui était de jeu je peux
aussi bien ouais je qu'aussi bien
voulait souffler si vous voulez aider
moi mais je suis sûr vous parlez de très
très bien alors le compte de la misère
était que si c'était que et pilar
serviable je vois bien qui fait un
effort conciliant alors le compte de la
lisère le compte de la misère ces deux
aspects que beck mais j'ai sa mère non
mais ça c'était que baiser sa mère l'ami
jean d'ormesson votre idéal de bonheur
terrestre mais reprendre ça serait
démarrer un roman démarrer un faux bond
à la faute pour laquelle vous avez le
plus d'indulgence
les gens qui comptent pas bien votre
qualité préféré chez l'homme
deux pas de dieu sait quand et sentais
mieux je suis là local unique de voir
entrer à l'académie ce sera un exemple
alors il faut pas saluer en rouge voilà
votre qualité préféré chez la femme
oui je signe misogynie le pari je vous
le jure pas raison à chaque préfet la
femme c'est camille sée qu'elles
plaisent bien
c'est dur pour nous de faire défaut oui
c'est du principal défaut facile
cette cause est tellement bien ce que
vous détestez par dessus tout la musique
qu'il faudra rue le don de la nature que
vous aimeriez avoir
la rapidité par exemple excusez moi
c'est tellement mais non c'est très bien
c'est très bien j'aimerais j'aimerais
j'aimerais être comme moi mon âge jean
d'ormesson
commandant jérôme r
maintenant